hello there reject nation it is time for
the ultimate easter egg breakdown from
new rockstars as eric voss apparently
170 easter eggs have been discovered now
the digital release for no way home is
out there's always going to be more to
unpack about this movie always decades
worth realistically it's probably the
last spider-man no way home video we do
for a little while
two days without spider-man no well
what would we ever do with ourselves
there were weeks or you guys are like
well they haven't talked about
spider-man for weeks and then one week
we're like we're doing a bunch again
here we are that's what everyone wants
is to relive 2021 over again
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home is now
available in higher resolution and now
that i can actually pause and look at
the stuff instead of begging the amc
projectionist to freeze the frame i know
that's you back sure
in this movie that we just gotta
re-break down this film some of this
will be stuff that i found on my first
breakdown on release weekend which has
grown to be my most viewed video ever
thank you wow so much so to show my
gratitude to you and to the talented
artists who worked on this film i have
found well over 100 more details like my
final tally is close to 200 then i am
going to present to you comprehensive
near shot-by-shot analysis of everything
great about spider-man no way home i'll
never need to watch this again make it
less about my commentary now that we've
all seen the film okay over the studio
titles we actually hear mysterio's audio
from the post-credits scene of
spider-man far from home i managed to
send the elemental back to the
dimensional riff but i don't think i'm
gonna make it off this bridge alive in
his dying moments mysterio maintained
the lie of his illusions coming from an
interdimensional rift all the doom peter
parker but also ironically actual
threats yeah
risks become the actual crisis in this
movie
the marvel studios title card has been
updated so that on the r replacing
rocket is peter's portal arrival in
england
the way this movie will bring back other
peters through the same kinds of portals
far from home of course ended with the
credits cutting off peter's f-bomb
here a car horn censors it
the scene has been recreated almost
exactly down to the three extras behind
mj dressed just like the guys behind her
in the 2019 scene the even game the dude
with the phone wired earbuds just like
he had before attention to detail
those lucky sons of [ __ ] right there
can you imagine that you're just a
background player and now you're like
hey come back to be a
co-star
we need you the script supervisor
demands it we're even gonna give you a
speaking line my man
how cool is that absolutely all those
years later that's nuts them and
seriously the script supervisor deserves
all the credit because those are the
details they got to keep the most track
give it up for scripts and revisers
skip supervisors that's right but the
main difference of course is that mj now
wears the broken black dahlia necklace
that peter bought for her in venice and
gave to her in london to which she said
sorry it's broken
i actually like it better broken mj
knows things can never be perfect her
mantra is expect disappointment and you
will never get disappointed and that is
why she refuses to let peter say i love
you in order to leave things broken and
give him a reason to find her one
onlooker asks you're just a kid i nodded
that onlooker on the train at sam rainey
spider-man 2 in 2004 when toby mcguire
was unmasked he's just a kid
just a kid that peter's exposure was met
with gratitude leaving him with faith in
humanity but this peter's exposure is
met with hostility leaving him more
cynical as they swing through the city
they pass billboards for rogers and
musical which we saw in hawkeye and will
return in secret invasion there are also
billboards for fortnight and the hyundai
bionic five which did a cross
promotional campaign with the film its
slogan electrify your journey of course
tying in with electro there's also a
participation billboard because sony i
love that that's how they got their
product placement in there they want so
badly to be a part of the movie itself
oh my god they're like you'll see it for
like point five seconds if you pay
really really close attention that
equates to thousands of ps5 sales and
audi sales these screens show peter's
face with this mask covering half of it
a recurring image that we've seen in the
comics they land on queensborough bridge
with the nearby roosevelt island tramway
the same location as the final showdown
in the 2002 film they dropped past flash
on his phone is a tick tock feed of the
daily bugle official the account hosted
by betty brant leading up to the film's
release they pop out in front of del
mar's deli now labeled del mars 3 as
this is the third film in this trilogy
and we have seen this bodega destroyed
at least once the sign reads best
sandwiches in queens calling back mr del
mar's line in homecoming the best
sandwiches in queens and they are coming
out of the sewer actually because in
queens the subway turns into an elevated
train as you see in the background john
watts
details of the manhole cover and since
throughout these opening minutes we're
getting a ton of shout outs to the past
eras this has got to be a callback to
the closing shot of the amazing
spiderman they land outside
oh my god to help her and peter
accidentally grabs her butt and then
immediately says i'm sorry
i never noticed that
walking in on peter shirtless with
homecoming mj hands peter his i survived
my trip to nyc shirt that he wore in
homecoming also in this apartment his
poster for the feast fundraiser where
spiderman made his appearance and far
from home john watts directed the
sequence in one two minute long take
two minutes long in which tom holland
and zadea impressively scramble around
this place when peter whips the first
shade shut the animators made sure to
show that webbing shooting out of his
arm in his reflection in the cabinet and
when the last shade shoots back up it
looks like tom might actually improvise
webbing it shut in order to keep it down
i think what's so cool about that one
shot too is that not only does it
emphasize the comedic hijinks but it
really emphasizes the tension as well oh
yeah so you get the best of both worlds
the comedy plus the suspense and just
wrapped in this beautiful blanket this
tortilla of enjoyment is that right
watson this is tortilla yeah yeah rye
watson yeah what's copper
or todd or whichever all the cats love
spiderman cat cats there's a lot of cats
here you got a lot of cats j jones
jameson's graphic shows protester signs
calling for peter to be locked up
another calling him a criminal with
devil horns this awkward photo of
peter's actually there's a criminal
photo that we saw in the far from home
deleted scene and then over on the far
right is a sign reading it was better
when you were blipped wow
trio of terror front page as well as an
us weekly that compares mj to liz holy
[ __ ] from the academic decathlon of dc
in homecoming another headline reports
mysterio douses hydro man in venice
because in far from home they initially
thought the elemental in venice was the
longtime spidey villain hydra man morris
bench god damn it's it's videos like
this that remind you why new rock stars
is amazing right finding these
production design details that otherwise
would have never been celebrated
properly 99.9 of people are not gonna
notice this at all and you have to have
that amazing cia technology to go zoom
enhance in order to understand what it
is you're dealing with somewhere out
there a set dresser is watching this
video with a single tear
rolling down their face
with andrea buchelli's time to say
goodbye
jameson also has some spare bottles of
his supplements throughout the place
showing how his whole new fancy studio
the whole business was really paid for
by those pills the daily news front page
has photoshopped peter mj and ned using
their yearbook photos and for the first
time we see mj's last name watson making
michelle jones watson the variant of
mary jane watson of this universe time
magazine calls peter iron man junior how
did that teenager become tony stark's
heir apparent all this echoing the same
sentiments of team mysterio from far
from home as if this could have been
headlined that they scripted for the
media peter gets coated in green paint
this is actually from a deleted scene
with tom holland's brother harry holland
you'll notice the graffiti behind peter
reads ramos for embarrassing matt rabbos
spider-man comic artist who partnered
with dan slott international news is a
ticker reporting interpol issues arrest
warrant for czech republic's night
monkey showing how your people are still
unsure if spider-man and night monkey
for far from home are the same person
like the narrative that spider-man
protects new york but sometimes europe
yeah absolutely and then if also if he
ever gets in trouble again he can always
fall back on that night monkey persona
you know that's true
but then he would need the night monkey
outfit from the avengers people that's
right no one would know who he is
sorry europe sorry europe you're screwed
you don't have spider-man anymore all
you got is the the ability to walk
around naked or whatever it is you
freaks do freaks or americans and then
political turmoil continues in new
asgard suggesting that king of
valkyrie's rule over that colony is
struggling so we could see more of in
love and thunder the b-roll they show of
tower bridge shows none of the drones in
the open air or spider-man's heroics but
just the moments when he and mysterio
were obscured in the tower walkway as
peter wrecked those drones showing more
obviously mysterious manipulations
because if they showed peter fighting
those drones that would hurt the
narrative that team mysterio wanted out
there that it was peter controlling the
drones clever virgin cleary name seen on
his badge is an odd to agent albert
cleary the dodc comptroller in the
comics photographs are taken of a photo
of ned and mj from homecoming as well as
peter's iron spider charging point all
these cables plugged into one outlet but
you'll notice the armor itself is
missing we see tony's eateth glasses
from far from home that case just left
open showing how peter must see this
every day as a reminder of tony and it's
on a stack of ps4 not
at all
dumpster diving for old consoles and
stuff now during the interrogation peter
where's his the physics are theoretical
but the fun is real shirt that he wore
when tony dropped him off back home in
homecoming agent cleary says nick fury
has been off planet for the last year
what yes nick fury and far from home was
actually the skrull taylos a storyline
that we're probably gonna revisit in
secret invasion now i'm wondering if
cleary but the fact that he knows this
could also be a scroll clear he's able
to get negan by tricking him into
correcting his misstatement when mj told
you that peter was spider-man
[Music]
what's up i knew way before mj did i was
spider-man's guy in the chair and a fun
detail here compared to mj's observation
room that you see in the reflection
ned's room has way more agents watching
as they all know this is the suspect
who's going to squeal now the news
good detail
that was set in 1999 when he dressed
like travolta and pulp fiction and then
matt murdock enters which we will all
applaud for the standing o that he
deserves you guys hear that story about
our charlie cox snuck into a theater
with his wife to watch spider-man no way
home and no one clapped
mcu movies ruined half the people left
the theater story was crazy ben affleck
came in and punched charlie face
that's great
thank you
[Applause]
but i love how the dialogue here is a
total meta commentary on the insanity of
this moment peter says what is happening
because indeed charlie cox matt murdock
in the mcu does raise a lot of questions
about the canonicity of all the netflix
marvel series and charlie's first words
are that's great thank you because this
is simply great and i'm sure charlie is
pretty grateful for it or he was just
wrapping up a phone call and they wanted
to cut to the chase a little quicker
you're two and a half hour spider-man
nope charlie cox improvised that
exchange he was all based on personal
experience what he was doing was imagine
on the other line was kevin feige he
called him being like do you want to be
back in the mcu that's great thank you
daredevil reboot shirt now john favreau
if you remember played foggy nelson in
the 2003 ben affleck daredevil which
charlie cox said he and favreau tried to
reference in a line that got cut and
there was a line i think it got cut i
don't think it made it in the final
thing but there was a line where
he was trying to remember something
that happened and he and he he said
yeah i i can't remember what happened
i'm a little foggy about that behind
peter is another newspaper he saw on
jameson's wall web of destruction
showing peter's damage at the staten
island ferry and the washington monument
in homecoming and tower bridge and far
from home but matt murdock proves he
does have his daredevil reflexes
hey
but i love how peter's hand was already
ready there to catch that brick because
he has spider sense and on that brick
the person misspelled the word believe
as if refusing to write the word lie in
front of mysterio they move into happy's
condo
alarm system
yeah notice how may punches in the right
code on her first try probably because
happy's passcode was something like one
two three four pretty sad lapse in
security that we learned in far from
home what's your password
password now what is your password
password the word password you're the
head of security and your password is
password i don't feel good about it
either we see several of happy security
badges calling back him telling everyone
to wear the matches in iron man 3 but he
actually might have swiped a bunch on
his way out knowing that his clearance
was going to be revoked so he could have
used someone else's badge to steal all
that stark tech notice how peter carries
all five of those heavy suitcases just a
cool little detail showing how strong
the kid is that is cool
from the iron man films that we saw him
bickering with and homecoming good yes
yeah no no put that down that's worth
more than you or me but now he clearly
just misses tony you can also see his
boxing mask and gloves on the table from
iron man 2. we saw iron man 2. now in
the credits of this movie they shout out
downton abbey which is a call back to
him loving downton abbey and iron man 3
but folks do you never see it in the
movie in our previous breakdown we just
pointed some random frame on the shelf
saying that was down to naby but it
wasn't so anyone else who has that in
their video just clearly watched ours
and stole it from us anyway
shut up all out
there's actually another one later in
the laundry area oh but now that stark
industries was shut down she'll be
stealing her crayons from applebee's
like we did in the background we hear
the news you'll put the captain american
shield on the statue of liberty
that looks ridiculous
delivery alone
yeah details throughout this movie
foreshadow the statue of liberty final
act and how most people in new york are
against putting cap's shield on that
statue wait a minute do you remember
that one no i mean that must have been
like really enhanced audio or something
like that or is that like one thing they
threw in there i think they put some
stuff in there oh maybe dang is that the
new phase we're headed to is every time
the movie gets released there's gonna be
more it's like reverse george lucas
scenario where they add more interesting
things because yeah that was clean
footage and that enhancement sounded
natural yeah
wow
that line actually might have quickly
cleared some stuff up
that i was never confused on and just
accepted it yeah they probably put the
shield up there
the shield falling is what almost causes
mj to fall to her death and it's
literally on that shield where peter
almost makes his worst decision so
really the people in new york were right
from the get-go this shield being added
to the statue's bad news subtle detail
that's pretty
son of a hard
boosted the iron man painting in the
style of the obama what poster from iron
man oh sweet nighttime security monitor
you can also see that he swiped the
recreation of the cap shield that tony
and coulson had in that movie when they
facetime mj's reading maya angelou's i
know why the caged bird sings she always
reads celebrated progressive authors and
on her wall is that photo of her ned
from homecoming also a photo that she
took of pigeons in venice and far from
home and the drawings she drew of peter
and coach wilson in homecoming oh i know
i just like coming here to sketch people
in crisis
it's you betty brant says
go get him tiger which of course is mary
jane's catchphrase for peter in the
comics and in the 2004 film go get him
tiger a supporter screams
this is darnold aptly an actor in
zendaya's long time assistant also among
that shouting we hear
i s zack cherry
flip guy return for a vocal cameo after
we saw him in homecoming okay can you
hear him say do a flip
[Music]
and after he returns something i caught
that the first time bus and chung chi
should boy cleve coming at you live on
the bus
do a flip
the martial arts has a youth so i'm
going to try and grade this fight as
we're going flash thompson shows off his
memoir flashpoint it's titled a nod of
the dc comics major crossover event
inside we see the mural of scientists
how it's been expanded from just howard
stark in previous films and all the
other famous real world scientists
include jim erskine as well as hank pym
and then if you look closely oh that is
george washington carver's head a
shrunken ant-man with a nearby pym
particle vial mr harrington's different
man he's a scientist sure clearly he
photoshopped himself into but also on
that yearbook page under chess club is a
photo of that blip girl sue lorman
mentioned and far from home though it
looks like she's given a different name
here flash's photo is wow good catch
taken outside so fancy and then all the
cards in this display actually lists
famous spider-man comics writers peter
unmasked by j.m strzezinski that's a nod
to j michael scherzinski who wrote the
peter unmasked issue of the civil war
comics also wrote the famous one more
day story line that is based on t
defalco or tom defalco k boussiek for
kurt busiek and p david or peter david
oh man spiderman comics writers as peter
walks down that spiderman movie loves
spiderman right it's a black and white
film now i asked people on twitter if
they could identify this matthew on
twitter pointed out that this is the
same cafeteria from the movie love simon
and although this scene is not from love
simon that movie did shoot in the same
atlanta high school as john watts shot
these spider-man movies so this is
actually a side short film that john
watts shot on location oh cool
because before he directed the
spider-man movie he worked with a short
film group called waverly flams all
those shorts you can still find on
youtube now on the roof graffiti shows
different spider-man co-creators you can
actually see that same stick catch the
dick on the beast truck throughout the
movie but not that one
peter parker and his fighter minions his
hypnotic spider senses seduced joan
watson now while peter does not really
have hypnosis powers this line does
foreshadow how in this movie the memory
spell wipes the memory and gaslights mj
so in a way that ends up happening as
peter leans over to kiss him yes as it
does peter you guess
as peter gets his college rejection
letters dummy reassembles the lego death
star set that peter and ned worked on in
homecoming but then at the end dummy
breaks it like ned did in that movie
this parallels the way the actual death
star was destroyed twice
in the third movie the star wars trilogy
i love that parallel that just makes me
so happy i think that's my my favorite
use of all the other brands we owned by
disney when i saw hey it's like when ned
dropped it but i love the idea of john
watts being like you know we can also
parallel the star wars trilogy
hey some fan out there came specifically
for this this is so deep as peter swoops
down to mj's shop his small silhouette
in the sky shows that he was in his iron
spider suit at first and then the
nanobots retracted on its descent but i
guess he was still holding that
acceptance letter all the while so the
bots had to like retract around his
pinch fingers but when he lands you can
see mysterio decals on both the lamppost
and on the nearby wall and there is
another banner for that statue of
liberty renovation as peter approaches
the sanctum sanctorum on the mailbox on
the right is the graffiti name romania
for john romita another spider-man
comics writer and then on the inside one
of the apprentices is played by emily
fong long-time marvel studios production
employee wong portals in from upstairs
you can actually see the mechanical
crimson bands of cedar act that strange
tossed on kaecilius hanging on the wall
there wong i guess just didn't feel like
carrying his luggage downstairs makes
sense i would use sling rings for that
too now strange's mug reads oh for
[ __ ] sake and now that multiverse
madness is bringing in fox x-men later
patrick stewart professor x it truly is
foreign that strange's world is heating
up he also wears a hoodie of his alma
mater colombia probably rubbing it in
for peter for getting rejected from all
these elite schools and showing how
strange stays connected with this
university and can just talk to them
something peter failed to even consider
trying peter says it's not about me i
mean this is really hurting a lot of
people peter actually unknowingly
repeats the ancient one's core lesson to
strange in the 2016 film is not about
you and that is what makes strange want
to help peter wong warns strange about
his memory wipe spell called the runes
of cough call that spell travels the
dark borders between known and unknown
reality it's too dangerous
we've used it for a lot less do you
remember the full moon party at comtaj
no exactly indicating strange has used
this dangerous reality warping spell
before one of many violations that
probably led to the crisis of multiverse
madness yeah you reckless bastard
which might be his way of saying don't
include me in the memory wipe spell so
that i can remember peter and you can
see behind wong is the kamatosh
courtyard that he's returning to now
peter parker's seeking dr strange's help
this way to make everyone forget that
he's spider-man is a reference to the
one more day storyline which actually
ends in a similar place with mj and
peter's best friend forgetting that he
is spider-man after asking strange to
exclude mj from the spell he then
remembers ned oh my god
what is a net yeah strange then pulls
out a chunk of the magic to observe ned
closely something he doesn't do for the
others maybe an indicator that ned has
the hidden sorcerer abilities and
strange can now see it here
i i i said that in the last breakdown
you did dude new rockstars have been
watching your video yeah
yeah
yeah i'm the
i'm the
guy in the chair there's sorrow in here
no one knows it all you're the new rock
star intelligent being living amongst
ordinary humans
because i uh stopped the video last
reaction to point that out something
that i pointed out that a lot of other
people
pointed out too
you originated it though i originated no
one else ever pointed out yeah in fact
during our first viewing of the film you
stopped you were like it's ned he just
gave him the powers just then it has
magic happen by a doctor strange day oh
my god the spell's been cast we missed
all the dialogue
what's going on right now what's going
on with this important piece of
information i was too busy telling you
my theory and that's how all our reviews
get made
we're just saying our rotten tomatoes
yeah let's check it with that we're good
now when the sanctum shakes knocks over
an artifact in the lobby this is the
same delicate stupid thing that thor
knocks over in ragnarok then peter
shouts basically everyone that knew that
i was spiderman before should still know
and the moment peter gives us our rule
by which the multiverse men cross over
right before strange sees the purple
silhouette of the lizard the building
that's strange oh cool
over peter's shoulder
villains a hulking figure at first i
thought sandman but based on the muscle
definition i think this is actually
venom who also crossed over into the mcu
only briefly during this event and
behind lizard you can start to see
glowing dots for dozens more just a hint
right here early in the movie that
beyond these nearer crossovers are even
more multiversal threats strange says
you changed my spell six times five
times they disagreed but peter asked
strange to exclude mj and ned in may and
happy and then everyone who knew before
that's five so strange actually might
have secretly adjusted the spell a sixth
time to exclude himself and wong because
he loves peter so much
you know what also could have happened
he could have been so flustered by the
situation that he didn't either properly
counted it was stead they get in anger
and just had a little bit of a slip up
and thought
i don't know man that that just doesn't
seem plausible whatsoever
whatsoever
later as peter glides down to the bridge
i like how he used his wingsuit webbing
again it retracts here but his heads-up
display reads edith offline since the
dodc shut down the whole edith network
which is also why the voice has changed
now now when he retracts his armor his
suit underneath is wrinkled i just love
that little detail reflecting how it was
crammed up against his body actually
later in this day you can see how his
blue button up is also super wrinkled
another cool detail i like that he needs
to hire his clothes shadow on the side
of the car just to match his silhouettes
oh dope wow love it love it it's idp and
as we were included by the enneagram
book we saw on peter's bedroom earlier
rearrange these you get the body
spidey's plural a clue for the multiple
spideys in this movie
63 a5m 3 a nod to the amazing spider-man
number three in 1963 the comic debut of
doc ock who makes his mcu debut in the
scene the footage that the girl in the
car watches on her tablet is actually a
delayed live feed from the daily bugle
helicopter you can see peter waving at
the camera on the tablet ah that
[Music]
of december 28 1922. after peter's
rambling speech the mit woman responds
you didn't rehearse that did you peter
yeah it is this failure that later leads
peter to script out and rehearse what he
wants to say to mj in the final scene
hockey is revealed
hi there peter hello there peter hola
hello peter
elephant's
you see how his claws glow red this is
how that film indicated when the claws
were in control and he asks what have
you done with my machine i don't know
what you're talking about i don't know
what machine the power of the sun in the
palm of my hand calling back his line
from that film the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand when doc ock
lifts the concrete cylinder over him i
love how john watts briefly frames him
directly down the barrel of that
cylinder really cool shot composition
there and i like how
peter it's like a bond movie
as the fight progresses like he webs
down one of his claws and then right
after he webs a second claw to the car
door to try to slow him down now really
cool detail here as peter suspends the
suv over the tracks i heard that fight
was originally much much longer
and that there were some like previz
effects that involved doc hawk and
goblin clashing at first oh that would
have been actually fighting maybe
they'll maybe they'll show like a
deleted pre-vis you know when they show
like here's the storyboards of what it
was supposed it's not full deleted scene
have i set you up for some good pause
react commentary absolutely thank you
nailed it thank you i think you nailed
it there i was like oh got it alley-oop
yeah
maybe they'll show that to us maybe down
the road would be cool i felt like that
fight could have gone on longer yeah it
was too short movies too short movies
too short
necessary pausing
justify the video
yeah aren't you glad you clicked on in a
wide shot of that bridge you could see
the name andrew graffiti on the bridge
column i'm pretty sure toby and andrew's
names appear everywhere in this movie
really and a brief shot back on the
bridge another cool detail no one else
having escaped the license plate reads
6306 asm for the amazing spider-man
number six in 1963 that was the debut of
kurt connors the lizard whom doctor
strange is dealing with at this moment
in the sewers doc absorbs peter's
nanotech something that he's able to do
thanks to oscorp's nanotechnology i'm
something of a scientist myself i read
all your research on nanotechnology
really brilliant i'd like to thank harry
osborne and ozcorp industries for
providing it that taught me so much
it taught me so much right there that it
was set up in the previous films
and it totally flew over my head i was
like isn't that a koicky dink that is
tentacles or just abs
meld with the nano technology like that
yeah peter doesn't have to do anything
he thought ahead as if i ever encounter
nanotech i better be able to absorb that
right
quick but no yes it's neat to see but
that actually is in line his tentacles
aren't but now technology i forgot about
that but that was just for the tritium i
thought so too but hey maybe he just
always kept it on hand or something i
don't know eric you're always right
there's a there's connective tissue
enough and when doc ock tries to stab
him peter's nanotech shifts from his
helmet to his chest and they mixed in a
little ping sound effects so we know doc
hawk didn't stab him just skewered his
necktie
peter's able to pair his os with doc
ock's arms since doc ock's arms are
controlled via neural link these smart
arms are controlled by my brain through
a neural link
nanowires feed directly into my
cerebellum and otto stands
now in the undercroft there are actually
a total of six cells eventually filled
by the five multiverse men of this movie
plus one more that is filled by the tree
that peter accidentally catches six
means that strange anticipated catching
venom as well and you can see how
strange his face is scratched now since
he had just fought the lizard doc asks
what is this a birthday party calling
back tony stark referencing strange's
jimmy kimmel bit when they first met
what is your job exactly besides making
balloon animals around the falling
sanctum you can see various pages from
spell books have been pinned up on lamps
to dry out never a good idea to rip out
pages from spell books folks downstairs
is a creepy doll that turns them they
know what they're doing tick tock is a
cosplayer dressed as a green elf looking
just like tom holland's character in
pixar's onwards oh [ __ ]
that's easter egg peter tracks down
electro and sandman same man helping
peter because they were on good terms at
the end of the 2007 film now one shot
shows peter pulling together multiple
strands to beat electro mirrored from
what he did you're doing this to beat
the electro in this
nice when electro and sandman get
trapped in the cells in the foreground
you can see the control panel showing
five lit up icons for each cell the
fifth one lit up for the tree there is a
sixth unlit button for the cell that
will soon be occupied by norman i'm
telling you one of these cells was going
to be for venom i mean i know that there
was a deleted scene that they didn't do
with venom that were supposed to come
into the finale but i do wonder if like
something with that was going on in the
world some virus that was specific think
of anything might have caused issues
with that actually happening right i
don't know the best conclusion you could
draw i guess so that's probably the only
thing i could think of all the
parameters they were able to work around
not that one got to keep tom hardy
healthy not that one uh keep him sick
protect tom hardy i think it's because
this was the first ever anti-back set
yes and tom hardy was like
i'm not going on your set unless
everyone's fixed
eddie
we need to get our pfizer
[Laughter]
i will not eat mrs chen until she gets
her booster
norman osborne shatters his goblin mask
the framing in the alley matches the
framing of toby peter leaving his suit
behind in the 2004 film but in both
cases those characters get dragged back
into the game but it is interesting to
note that goblin goes straight back aunt
may because assuming he was transported
from the rainy verse right after
learning peter was spider-man at
thanksgiving sometime around that scene
when he similarly cowered in front of
the mask in his home his next move there
was to go for the heart which in that
movie was also ant-may the feast
billboard tagged with mysterio was right
actually is a word bubble that says meet
queen's own spider-man uh i don't know
about you guys
did you notice it uh oh you mean the big
graffiti of him with the mysterio on his
head or maybe he was just a nope
anti-spider-man i definitely noticed
whatever it is you're talking about
though
to me that looks like the symbol from
the x-men it does
and they've already referenced for
[ __ ] sake once i'm telling you vos
just watches our reactions and he's
gonna put this in his follow up right
now i found one more detail whole break
that does not mean stop or cancel this
man that's clearly an x-ray
i mean yeah it's kind of hard to deny
that circle and an x it's pretty simple
in fact that's why a lot of people
didn't attend xavier school for the
gifted because the x symbols everywhere
confuse the [ __ ] out of me this is not a
welcoming environment
inside norman wears a green coat and
purple sweats his colors in the comics
but also this is stuff he clearly got
from the donation bin meaning that he
walked into this facility wearing his
goblin suit but aunt may still wanted to
help him he says
someone's living in my house
oscar doesn't exist yes oscorp does not
exist in the mcu making it likelier that
peter's spider bite might have come from
stark tech i made a whole video about
that check it out it may mean while i
was wearing a blue jumpsuit with a red
sash throughout this movie she's almost
always wearing spider-man's red and blue
colors goblins
background signaling he's still in his
shifty goblin survival mode actually and
peter says he's shaking doughnuts not
your problem calling back toby's line in
the 2002 film that led to uncle ben's
death i missed the part where that's my
problem jay jonah jameson's chiron reads
why does spider-man hate national
landmarks showing the washington
monument in the tower bridge now if you
look closely you can see that peace
truck actually used to be for the forest
hills moving company
queens is historically peter parker's
neighborhood strange shows them the
machina cadavers its name coming from
the crystal of cadavers in the comics
used to try to resurrect the dead in a
strange spider-man team-up issue in this
case it will doom these men to their
deaths to make them literal cadavers
strange pushes peter's soul out of his
body but peter is able to use his spider
sense to control his limbs wavy lines
stretch out from his head which
strange throws a cloak of levitation
around peter giving us the caped
spider-man that we saw in the what if
comics and in episode five of what if
now on the newsstand is the people
magazine interview with liz allen from
homecoming he's a liar which i assume is
a defense piece for her father adrian
tomb since peter got him arrested
something maybe we could revisit morbius
but i like all this probably not
definitely passed with parker despite
these two never actually kissed in
homecoming it was in the trailer but not
in the final cut of the movie so really
this whole article is a distortion in
the mirror dimension peter tumbles down
the high line of manhattan and he passes
a billboard showing a t-rex skeleton
it's an interesting parallel to
strange's coming multiverse tumbling
past
on the train dr strange's eye of
agamotto briefly opens and illuminates
showing that this artifact still has
some power beyond being a mere time
stone fanny pack something else that we
will see in multiverse madness peter
uses the geometry of archimedean spirals
to string up strange shortly after
strange mentioned the grand calculus of
the multiverse geometry versus calculus
just showing how peter used the simpler
math to defeat his overthinking rival
norman says the line you know
i'm something of a scientist myself
peter and ed did their handshake from
homecoming but now ned produces a spark
out of that sling ring
peter takes them all into happy's condo
actually deleted scene would have shown
them in the elevator together bummed we
missed out on that on the way in we see
them on the security monitor elektra
causes some distortion on the feed and
then he uses his hand to zap the tv on
where we see a news poll on that statue
of liberty renovation showing 67 percent
of new yorkers disapprove of it love how
there's this whole like subplot about
that damn shield being built there i'm
against it personally personally i think
it ruins a historical landmark mm-hmm
how did the french feel about that who
cares what the french think america owns
it that's true
they get night monkey that's enough i'm
surprised so many new yorkers did not
approve of that though actually as a
detail like the fact that everything
about that has been people being opposed
to it is actually a surprise i feel like
people would be down for a captain
america shield but
the falcons now captain america that's
true black falcon that's black properly
black cap yeah black captain america
they need to put a black shield on the
stage i think we got the right messages
definitely a falcon of winners yorkers
are racist yeah but we're not but not us
we just make jokes
perpetuating the wrists black jokes
on the wall and happy's back room is the
name slots for dance lot another big
spider-man comics writer that stark
fabricator is the same kind of machine
that peter used to 3d print his new suit
on the jet and far from home and it is
powered by the specific era of the arc
reactor in iron man 2 when it had that
triangular inlay tony stark later
replaced this with new versions showing
why these old ones would be stored may
and doc och briefly connect in the
kitchen and not to them getting married
at one point in the comics
morgan stark reminding him of his
daughter penny who would be around the
same age peter plugs in the new
inhibitor chip to dock the claw lights
go from red to white as they did in the
2004 film to indicate auto regaining
control and notice on the fabricator
peter created profiles for each of his
patients c connors m dylan and osborne
but only max's cure is listed as
complete since as we see later when mei
tries to plug norman with the antidote
it does not work otto chats with norman
how does it feel norman
you're about to become whole again no
more darker half
just you
just me yes defoe uses his darker goblin
voice there teasing the goblin is about
to make his move also notice as he turns
around he is suddenly sweating bullets
despite not sweating that much seconds
before this yeah i gotta tell you guys
to this day when i see this footage it
blows my mind i mean we gotta meet
willem dafoe at the premiere thanks to
koi zhandra who always wants a shout out
whenever we mention that seeing him up
close he looks way older he does he does
looks significantly older yes
i was like a shake a hand but i don't
want to break you yeah i'm like you look
so non-threatening and i feel like you
look so sweet do you need me to hold
your hair you can help across the road
my dude
i'm surprised you volunteered for all
those stunts the camera adds like six
inches to your height as well as
whatever weight it puts on
all right guys you're gonna see some
cats coming in and out of here for a
while because they're hungry peter's
spider sense activates again like we saw
on the bridge we get another great dolly
zoom camera move now behind him on the
left here is actually howard stark's
expo bottle from iron man 2 but the
first person peter passes and his trance
is norman the source of the danger the
camera only pulls away from peter when
may enters the frame and she's burning
sage and she says what is it
it starts with blends the space
sage doesn't work can't just like yeah
raised to wed norman it only goes back
down when sandman asks what's happening
distracting peter over on the right and
in that moment of distraction norman
moves across the room to dummy which
even doc ock abuses suspicious based off
his expression after peter whips him
goblin reveals himself these are not
curses they're gifts gifts and curses a
call back to the 2002 film line this is
my gift
my curse also notice how devoe now shows
the gap in his teeth which he did not
have when he smiled before because in
the 2000s
as norman osborne but shifted to his
normal teeth when he transformed into
goblins really happy i always what he
noticed his teeth in that scene but i'd
never do that
in there
profile that was crazy more and more as
peter punches him showing how each hit
makes him stronger and crazier so goblin
hits may with his glider and bombs the
place on his way out he slices the daily
bugle van telecom tower which actually
does james in a favor because in his
really shitty broadcast after this
incident he's able to lie and say that
this was all spider-man's doing not
goblins and then may drops the big adage
and with great power there must also
come more responsibility great damn it
you got a lot to keep track of with your
power must also come from amazing
fantasy 15 when stan lee spoke at his
exposition you can actually see this
quote on marissa tomes title card in the
closing credits oh she dies peter says
okay
it's just me and you
calling back when may said this to peter
and homecoming just laying it out it's
just me and you which i read as may
referring to ben's recent death it was
just the two of them then and just the
two of them now now in ned's nana's
house they also have that photo of ned
and mj from homecoming showing how all
three of these friends had a different
copy of this and we see it now because
ned and mj really just want to be with
peter i think all this was intended to
be a back to the future photo style prop
to show how these two did have a version
of their life without peter in it now
lola also has a sewing machine but just
to be clear this is a different sewing
machine than the one peter has at the
end of the film we don't know that he
stole it we don't know that yeah i've
seen heavy spoilers thumbnail yeah
it's all coming down to that sewing
machine
or he swapped it out with something else
it's the same sewing machine there's
that partner's defeat yeah
stealing from old ladies i'm still not
over that teeth thing that is crazy i
yeah i'd never do that that is a crazy
little detail that is now endured for
like 20 odd more years i'm gonna do
watch this performance that was look at
his teeth look at that what are his
teeth regular one or his teeth now
noticeably perfect like a dog showing
its fangs it does make his face look a
little different though now that he
points it out yeah yeah it's like that's
how he gets a goblin face with his
natural teeth
andrew garfield spider-man enters the
film string theory
multi-dimensional reality
and matter displacement
all real interracial friends yeah
what's under there is actually james
corner's amazing spider-man theme i just
love the meta wordplay between andrew
and mj why do i need to crawl around
because this is not enough this is
plenty no it's not yes it is no it's not
it is oh yeah as if one past spider-man
is not enough which mj doubles down on
yeah i guess you just keep doing until
we find the real one ouch now when
andrew hops down from the ceiling the
sling ring portal has now pivoted to
face him turning on its axis from the
direction it was facing before just
showing how ned opened this portal in
order to find peter and so peter is how
the portal orients itself in the room
then
[Music]
great it's just some random guy
[Laughter]
and after teaching peter some critical
lessons about dealing with these groups
the three peters rally to
and
engineer
okay so uh connors marco dylan and um
yes he cannot bring himself to say
osborne's name because deep down he
doesn't want to cure him yet which toby
double checks i think i can make an
anti-serum for dr osborne i've been
thinking about it a long time
gotta cure all of them
right i also like the implication that
toby has been losing sleep over wishing
he could have cured osborne over all
these years instead of watching them die
and when toby talks about harry osborne
watch andrew here do you have a best
friend too
yeah i've always noticed that you did
he died in my arms
after he tried to kill me
andrew goes from pity for toby's friend
in his arms to surprise and empathy for
his harry also trying to kill him he's
just always trying to take attention
away isn't he that andrew garfield oh
he's just so living in the character
he's the guy on twitter writing all the
three hashtags
this whole time just trying to get back
on screen and we get the meme peter yeah
oh sorry sorry
yeah they all point at each other which
even the movie script directs as memes
when tony webb's a stool notice he still
has his scars on his wrist from the remy
films and again andrew's reaction is the
best you can't do that huh no how on
earth does that even anyway we're
getting sidetracked look this is what
we're gonna do yeah it takes him a solid
beat for andrew to finally take his eyes
off that scar andrew cracks toby's back
less deadly than what he did to gwyn
orwell fighting venom and spider-man 3
and thanos and rhino and the amazing
spider-man 2 and toby says but it's just
a self-talk maybe we should listen
though because you're you're amazing
just to take it in for a minute yeah
yeah yeah
you are amazing then electro appears and
the bolts form the shape of electro's
classic mask from the comics on his face
you actually see this shape again later
when he's zapping andrew ned is unable
to close his portal and that might be
because the other two times he opened
the portal the purpose he was seeking to
find peter was met so those portals
closed on their own but now ned's real
purpose deep down is to help this battle
he can't take his mind off the battle
and allow that portal to close at first
the three peters okay that makes a lot
more sense
in the face
magic is mental gross yeah toby says
gross despite andrew's webbing being
artificial unlike his webbing that comes
out of his body tom says i was in the
avengers the avengers
yeah that's great thank you what is that
oh you don't have the avengers is that a
bad are you the band calling back how
bruce compared the avengers to the
beatles in infinity war
like a band like like the beatles and
then when they leap each peter's jump is
unique to his respective era toby does a
double front flip tom does a frog pose
oh that is beautiful
he's just so beautiful he's an under the
legs whip as he would his movies and
then tom turns around to web his two
brothers to sling them along with him
and when he does this he uses the side
roll move that cap did when he was
fighting
[ __ ]
yes
i never thought of that
toby first andrew second tom third now
during the battle andrew webbs up the
lizard to restrain him but it takes a
while for the lizard to break out of it
compared to the 2012 movie when lizard
was able to tear out of the webbing
seconds later might be showing how
andrew spent these years strengthening
his webbing after
you know
there you
[Music]
film go is able to restrain electro
since his claws were designed to be
impervious to energy spikes and then
after notice how toby is holding his
chest because unlike andrew his suit was
not designed to be shock proof ned
finally brings doctor strange back i've
been dangling over the grand canyon for
12. i know i know in a way this is a bit
of payback for strange making loki free
fall for a half hour
i have been falling
for 30 minutes goblin shouts can the
spiderman come out
calling back his line in the 2002 film
can spiderman come out to play now when
strange lassoes the box and pulls it
away you can see goblin with both hands
on the box smiling because he just
slipped in that pumpkin bomb he cuts one
of dockhawk's arms and leaves them with
[Music]
the explosion caused mj to fall from the
scaffolding framing her just like gwen's
death drop except here turn on the side
and andrew retakes the plunge except
this time
instead of honestly yeah we're emotional
again
jesus christ
leave it in this one
as peter puts norman on that shield he
leaps up at one point and punches down
denting the metal yeah which totally
would have caved in his skull that
always stuck with me we're gonna stab
him with it the same way goblin died in
the 2002 film but also evoking
bringing down the shield on tony in
civil war a parallel that's even more
obvious since they are fighting upon
cap's shield but toby stops tom from
killing goblin no words just doesn't
want the kid to grow rageful and bitter
but goblin stabs him and tom literally
turns his body from one side to the
other he was in killing mode but now he
turns the cheek andrew sees this
hey nice catch
nice throttle toby's okay saying yeah
i'm gonna
step oh god the morning when harry
osborn stabbed him in the rainy films
purple cracks in the sky open up i've
broken this down before but the visible
silhouettes include madame webb getting
her own movie the superior spider-man
armor with multiple arms craving the
hunter getting his own movie scorpion
the original comics form black cat and
then later rhino and then i figure
everyone keeps calling mysterio based
off of the head but i don't think so
this guy walks with more of a timid step
and has a slender build i think this is
actually miles morales peter tells
strange to go through he looks more like
him
goodbye to each other thank you sir
call me stephen
thank you steven yeah
still feels weird calling back their
banter of course earlier in this movie
but also the very first time they met an
infinity war and joked about their real
names i'm peter by the way doctor
strange oh using their made up names um
i'm spider-man then peter hugs the other
peters
thank you thank you thank you thank you
a hug that was improvised by tom holland
to thank these past two eras of
spiderman so after the spell goes
through peter returns to the peter pan
donut shop a name with greater
significance now for a peter who has to
watch others through her window living
their lives without him mj oh wow yeah
that's the truth who must now grow up i
suppose this is meant to be the film's
stan lee cameo but really just to make
us do a double take and evoke deja vu
the way mj feels in the scene the script
also states that mj is meant to watch
peter go with quote a lingering sense of
recognition this plus the fact that she
is still wearing that broken black
dahlia necklace tells us that some part
of her still remembers peter it made or
she likes the necklace
which could be a nod to tony stark
always questioning how young she really
is back in civil war and the quote reads
when you help someone you help everyone
which is actually what is written on her
grave in the spider-man ps4 game in the
envelope peter moves into a new
apartment is due on the first of the
month don't be late yes his squalor
apartment evokes peter's crappy flat in
the rainy films and while the landlord's
voice is the fact that he reminds peter
the rant is definitely meant to remind
us of that guy we see that peter is
studying for the ged meaning peter's
academic records must have been wiped or
warped since if you think about it much
of his midtown high identity was really
wrapped up in his spider-man identity at
this point i did do another video
breaking down how exactly reality was
worked and who remembers what i highly
recommend you check it out on peter's
table is the we are happy to serve you
cup that mj gave peter in the cafe and
by the way that coffee cup is just a
generic new york area coffee cup that
appears in productions of literally
everything shot in that city it's not a
retreat they exist in real life this cup
isn't everything it's like saying i saw
one just the other day what is the cool
detail peter has that lego palpatine
figurine which was the first line we
heard spoken by ned in this trilogy in
homecoming and peter has a new song oh
that's good let's stitch together diy
finally without having avengers to build
his tech for him and design wise it's
made of a brighter fabric clearly
inspired by the designs of the other two
spider-men actually the closing credits
show his sketches of a new logo as he
swings through rockefeller's center
failing to make a cameo in the final
battle of hawkeye we get this awesome
closing frame almost a jump scare
because he zooms it right in on our
faces giving us an extreme close-up of
his new mask but up close like this we
can see it is textured in a porous
fabric gone are those mechanical
eyepieces this is just a cloth mask yes
a new beginning a fresh start baby that
is everything i spotted in this high
residential release of no way home but
folks there is still the 4k version
coming next month and there's going to
be a lot of deleted scenes commentary
lots of bonus footage gives me a lot of
time 600 miss details again so be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars you can
follow me on instagram break
down the post credits subscribe to
support this channel directly thank you
so much for watching bye
what did you notice in the venom yeah
and how to tie into when he was supposed
to be at the statue of liberty was that
guy really mexican is that guy the same
guy from ted lasso daniel rojas
new rock stars you crazy sons of [ __ ]
thanks for putting this together eric
voss you are the boss
boss boss boss voss haven't caught that
wild
kingping
anyway king boss
that was good
i was that big man i was seriously epic
congratulations not to work a lot of
work from all you editors
eric
you're all beautiful people
say hi to your mother for me